lancée à nice qu'il est avec nous vous
êtes rappeur journalistes et vous vous
allez voter eric zemmour peut-être
pourquoi pourquoi parce que je trouve
qu'il est cohérent sur beaucoup de
choses d'abord et je trouve qu'il ya
énormément de mépris envers lui et en
vers l'est la plupart des gens qui le
soutiennent et qui le représente
il nie la réalité qu'est ce qui vous
plaît chez eric zemmour ce que vous avez
fait un deal soirée car hcg 26 ans voilà
26 ans est vrai que et qu'est ce qui
vous plaît déjà il est cash ouais il
prend pas de gants malgré ce qu'on pense
pas déjà il a une bonne connaissance des
quartiers populaires et tous quand même
un mec a grandi dans le 9 3 ouais il
arrivait en tant qu'immigré avec ça me
fait d'accord avec sa famille où on you
buy
je veux dire je veux dire c'est pas non
plus la plupart des gens qu'on voit
aujourd'hui dans la politique c'est des
mecs et se sont fait sponsoriser depuis
le plus jeune âge c'est des rentiers ce
que tu dis aux gens qui disent eric
zemmour il nous fait peur bah je leur
dis qu'il faut pas en avoir peur en fait
on est en france on est dans un pays qui
est bien foutu les gens ils sont page
tarbes et aux dernières nouvelles
je pense que s'il est élu la plupart de
ces trucs même pour l'instant il a même
pas de programme déjà est déjà à dix ans
de prison et n'a pas de programme ouais
c'est vrai en plus il a
marqué une certaine émulation de revenus
offert une certaine comme on dit une
certaine enfin une adhésion et une
adhésion voilà de lui porte à ses idées
oui et moi je pense juste qu'il n'est
pas assez informés en fait sur sur
l'islam par exemple ce qui n'est pas
assez informés mais c'est à dire est ce
que vous vous êtes vous êtes musulman
oui vous êtes pratiquants oui et ça vous
dérange pas tout ce qu'il dit sur l'iss
à certaines fois ci mais je trouve que
c'est de la maladresse et qu'il est
juste mal informés on est juste là pour
leur maladresse hilal mauvaises herbes
il a le mauvais entourage il s'entend
je déjeune à eghezée mon moi et chant il
change d'avis que diriez quoi
déjà je vais direct on est très proche
par exemple à ce qu'il disait sur les
lgbt à l'école madame mais pense la même
chose que moi normalement si c'est une
vraie musulmane pratiquante alors déjà
on n'est pas là pour parler
s'est
offert des commentaires surtout
d'améliorer dans un parking un écho
depuis tout à l'heure je répète tout ce
temps j'ai arrêté de marmonner dans
votre barre
si je vais à la mosquée j'ai une famille
musulmane vole pas où je vais dire la
plupart des musulmans tradi toutefois
que je connais on va dire qu'on va même
qualifié de radical des fois ils sont
plus proche des catho de la manif pour
tous que des chants genre clairement
c'est pas on n'est pas si loin parce que
c'est vrai que j'ai trouvé avec moi ce
qu'ils disent sur liste avec ses draps
où on essayait tonné gilles devoir ray
mine de rien a nice c'est pour pour eric
c'est la métisse et j'entends avec avec
intérêt et c'est vrai que là pour moi
c'est problématique parce que je trouve
que vous légitimez ce qui dit alors je
sais pas quelles sont vos arrières
pensées éventuelle mais sur les
musulmans excusez moi c'est quand même
très violent ça oui maintenant j'ai moi
même été blessé par certaines parce
qu'ils me disent qu'ils savent que vous
voudrez bien sûr mais pas qu'ils
connaissent toutes mes idées politiques
sont mises journal des débats animés
c'est super pagne elle même elle est
très à gauche vous avez des débats non
mais vous moi je suis désolé mais vous
allez vous faire plumer enfin c'est ça
qui va se passer c'est que eric
l'alignement il expliqué il le dit c'est
l'islam est incompatible avec la graine
à ratifier quoi donc donc vous allez
vous faire plumer un à l'arrêter
maintenant qu'ils vont bien pour un
poulpe six par jour un vrai conseil
d'état quand c'est constitutionnel
migrer un arc les j'espérais renvoyer
rats parle de les renvoyer et en plus
ce sera facile quand il nous sort
l'histoire des villes qui arrivait que
c'est un mais mais un étudiant sur trois
quarts et déjà c'est un étudiant on n'a
plus envie de la france elle rayonne
dans le monde en fait c'est bon c'est
quand j'écoute liliane on peut se
balader je sais pas moi vers le jardin
et veulent par exemple ces conneries là
le 19e ce qui peut se balader un peu
là-bas vous voyez ce qu'elle apporte
l'immigration alors oui même dans même
dans des quartiers moi je connais des
dix lots saint pons couchepin un mec moi
je fais un mec de neuilly ou quoi je
connais des deals hausse j'ai un casier
judiciaire bah bravo un nom ouais c'est
pas une fierté d'ailleurs bas mais je
veux dire par là que je connais un peu
des gens dans le milieu clairement même
un terrain mais qu'un gérant de terrain
voilà il a des problèmes avec les
immigrés avec les clandestins qui
viennent vendre des fausses marlboro se
droguer et arraché des pauvres dames
maintenant au lieu d'embaucher des
guetteurs et l' embauche des vigiles